last season I remember when you and
Travis got engaged and it was so
exciting
and there was that you know a lot about
Scott's reaction how he's feeling like
you were a little upset about that I was
upset that they
chose to take my fairy tale and like
include
that part of it Kourtney Kardashian not
exactly thrilled that her ex Scott
Disick played such a big role in her
engagement to Travis Barker on the
Family's reality show I don't really
think that me getting engaged is like
about Scott yeah Court's doubling down
on that sentiment on the not skinny but
not fat podcast revealing she was upset
the Kardashians producers made Scott a
focus during her big moment and then it
just bothered me like these people that
you know wherever production are like
making the choice of what my story is
but aren't you an executive producer I
am and so I you know we watch Cuts we
give notes those notes weren't addressed
and it just bothered me yeah that was
also his the only really thing that his
perspective right you'll remember Travis
went all out popping the question on the
beach in Santa Barbara last October
[Music]
I feel like I'm living in a fairy tale I
couldn't have dreamed of anything more
perfect and after court said yes her
sister Chloe met up with Scott to see
how he was doing don't get me wrong
I'll always love your sister so I wasn't
that caught off guard I mean I thought
they had already been married the way
that she was talking so it wasn't crazy
thank God because at another time in my
life if I would have heard that life
would have been over for me I think it
just bothered me because I felt
like this is my fairy tale and I was
like why can't we show The Happy The
Happy Ending why do we have to focus on
this and I get it's TV and blah blah
blah the reasons but
to me I was not having it I was like you
wouldn't do this to anyone else fast
forward a few months and two weddings
later kravis is living our best lives
and
yeah A source told E.T back in May that
court is emotionally done with Scott and
putting all her focus on newlywed life
with Travis I'm not putting my energy
there our source added she couldn't be
more in love and happier I feel like I
am living like a fairy tale
making like new memories and new moments
and I don't necessarily want Scott at
all of them
[Music]